hey so i i've been i guess struggling
with how to pronounce the name of joe
biden's white house press secretary
and i got yet another voicemail
admonishing me about it remember our
voicemail number is 219
to david p take a listen
hello david this is a fan my name is sue
and i mean this in the most kindly way
since you will be pronouncing
the white house press secretary's name
hundreds of times
i would suggest that you pronounce it
correctly yes it's jen
saki with a a a short
no yes a soft a instead of
instead of saki jen saki bye bye
so i at the beginning i would say gen
saki
and then a few people wrote to me and
said david it's saki so i switched to
saki and then over the weekend
i got a dozen emails saying david it's
saki and now i'm being told it's sake
i am going to pronounce it saki and the
reason why
is that jen saki recently did an
interview with a longtime friend of hers
and he pronounced it saki i assume he
knows how it's said
so i'm going to be pronouncing it jen
saki until someone explains to me a good
reason why i should reverse course once
again
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we've got resignations
we've got black history month drama in
utah schools
we've got more statements about the
lab hypothesis of the coronavirus all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com